hey what's up this is Chris Pratt and
I'm Tiffany at it we're here talking
about the lego movie to the second part
yeah and we're gonna share with you all
of our first first big red carpet events
a movie that I did that I don't want to
say the name of that came out a long
time ago in the early 2000 at the Magic
Johnson movie theater for okay and all
exciting they had some posters up of me
and there's my first highly being a lead
in the movie and nobody shot it and I
wear the best dress I could find at the
spot me yeah I was on a TV show called
Everwood on The WB some years ago maybe
fifteen seventeen years ago and are in
our first season we were nominated for a
People's Choice Award I had like long
hair at the time I it was good you have
a man but no I never pulled off the man
bun I just had like long curly hair like
yeah yeah just like that
did you ever have cornrows I never got
to know I never knew cornrows oh there's
a new first we'll get back to you on
that the first thing you do when you're
preparing for a new role read the script
over and over and I like you know I try
to find a body lead you know body lead
is know a body lead is the walk it's
what you're gonna lead with when you
want halt when you're walking yeah oh
and the walk first thing I do when I'm
preparing for a new role is find out how
much money I'm getting paid right Dan
then I try to figure out how much of
myself can I use in this character and
then when there's a whole bunch of stuff
I do it
that's personal you have a paper
template first embarrassing moment on
set and I don't know if I've ever really
been embarrassed on set it's like you
have a path cast yeah but I always own
it I love yeah I'm doing it during the
middle of the scene yeah yeah I've done
that one time I did a scene and my boob
was out the whole scene and I didn't
know really you know just know I'll be
on enough analysis
you know isn't that brown to shut them
down and that brother's gonna be like oh
my beautiful bit do you
I think mine are time all I got ya there
I'm like one generation away from just
not having it now you can't be nobody no
no no sir it would you'd be it didn't
have to be sucking a long time to get
anything completely Italian on this
they're very small
Oh what's your first impression of Chris
Pratt we actually didn't meet until just
about five minutes ago yeah well we've
met before then we met before then when
do we meet ain't no audition what we met
at audition we actually had to play
together if you don't remember that cuz
you don't have like memory like me wait
what did I remember are you messing with
me
what was this for when was this this was
like probably eight or nine maybe ten
years ago I can't blow it was like
improv stuff though and it was like like
moving everybody like this person effort
babies pair of people up is that oh
really
it was improv you don't remember that I
think you never do improv I know I think
you might maybe I do you think that I'm
first memory that comes to mind from
your stint on the OSI oh okay um Chris
Brown was in the episode that I was in
and I worked with Rachel Bilson and I
had an iPod and I was listening to this
music and what were you guys filming it
we were filming in on rosecrans in the
studio down there on Manhattan Beach
yeah like a lot of people around women
yeah that's what it was right there - I
was a background employee are you you
lying nope the world's best extras of
all time you were a nice drawing Oh Lucy
yes I always looked into the camera - ah
speed unique
you guys the extra OC also once we give
I was an extra on Dawson's Creek uh
Ottawa shows because they made him one
black girl to walk around do you feel
like now that since you have done extra
work that your relationship to extras on
films is different than other actors may
have probably because I talked to
everybody in school I talked to all the
extras and stuff unless they're creepy
with just a lot of creepy extras but if
they don't come off pretty I'll talk to
everybody
do you talk to extras oh hell no first
memory that comes to mind from filming
girls trip sitting in the director's
office and him telling me that he's not
sure if I'm gonna look old enough to
play this part and they Queen Latifah
coming in and fan I'm just gonna assume
that Deena's a genius and she skipped a
few grades and got into college and
that's how she met us and I said no just
know that Deena got some good genetics
is she older than all you [ __ ] first
big purchase after getting your first
major role I bought my mom a house when
I was 23 years old
oh wow you've been rich a long time yeah
that's nice that was good
I know I was I wasn't rich I had just
enough to buy the house and so I was
where I was rich for a second and then I
was poor but my mom had a house I've
been buying things for a long time well
you know I was on a TV show called the
Carmichael's and I bought a house on the
second season and I paid it off within
three years first car Geo Metro yeah
okay the first one that I paid for with
my own money was 86 Toyota Camry oh yeah
1200 bucks
our celebrity you ever met Maxine Waters
yeah when I was in sixth grade I wrote a
paper on it and if she showed up for
this cuz I had one that I'm gonna write
the paper I'm also just copy the
newspaper article yeah I played to write
and I thought I ran it or just not about
three years ago and I was like you know
I don't know
remember you telling me that I was gonna
make it meant you were proud of me and
that I'm an intelligent young lady I
just want you to know that that paper I
wrote about you I stole out of a
newspaper like don't worry this is like
how do you think I get to work first
celebrity I ever had an encounter with
was Randy Macho Man Savage that's the
attack Airport
I just loved WWF wrestling at that time
and my brother and I was like ah he was
there and he was wearing the whole getup
and he's like all jacked and had his
cowboy hat sequence cowboy yeah I was
like you're Randy Macho Man Savage and
he goes yeah brother I was like oh oh oh
I must have been like ten or nine times
like that
you got bit too late for it at that
point yeah I've been to an airport I
wasn't a fast yeah your parents must be
rich
no no no we like it affords it you know
we we I don't know how we ever went on
that trip cuz I were rich first thing
you do when you have time off first
thing I do what I have some up sleep
yeah wait you know just like the normal
routine things back home I have a son so
I like to take him to school pick him up
from school hang out with them spend
time with them because usually when I'm
on the job it means I'm on location and
then I'm away from home so it's that and
it's also like clean my house like come
back and I'll be like wow I've been gone
for six months look at this place I just
do it top to bottom
you clean it yourself yeah that's what's
up I like cleaning my own house - but
I'm orrible oh yeah as I'm sleepy yeah
first time you realized you were famous
yeah about three weeks ago yeah well I
did a show on Miami and I didn't do the
normal Tiffany Haddish stuff and then
when I was like on every new thing we're
not doing well at that show I was like
like four or five days like I made it I
had this I had this moment where I was
eating at a restaurant and there was
this table of dudes that were really big
and kind of intimidating and they were
just like looking at me and immediately
I went - oh man I think these guys are
gonna like jump me or something you know
and they catch me looking and they
didn't look away they just kept looking
I was like oh no I had to walk out and
go hey I was like
hello and he goes you won that ever
would show I was like oh yeah thank god
yes I am yeah I am
we have no choice by mob I don't know I
mean I've had that famous I got we were
in Brazil to do something for maybe for
Avengers or something like that they
knew the hotel out saying that there was
3,000 people or something like that just
like hanging out down down below and I'd
look out my I'd peek out the window the
glass did go crazy in the last time we
were there we all got really drunk we
put on starboy and we just pumped it up
and pumped up the music out of the car
open up the doors everyone took their
phones out I was like no phones man no
phones let's just have a moment and
everyone put their phones down and we
danced to that song for like three
minutes in the middle of the street it
was so sick first piece of advice you'd
give someone who's trying to become an
actor take acting classes that's good
look to yourself and try to identify
something about you that no one else has
and and really focus on that and figure
out what that thing is and in work in
that world because that's something
you'll always be able to offer that no
one else can what do you have that
nobody got a pass oh so much so much
time let me ask that a lot
it's called it that's what you have that
nobody else has it will be right hello
I'm pregnant now I know where I'm at a
lien I gave you kids is on the air yes
[Laughter]
[Music]